america's infrastructure is in the
spotlight this week as the senate
prepares for its first
vote on 1.2 trillion dollar framework
which has bipartisan support according
to a new cbs news poll the majority of
americans 59
support president biden's infrastructure
proposals there is overwhelming support
for specific funding for building and
repairing roads
and bridges rural broadband and care for
children and the elderly
only on cbs this morning our errol
barnett spoke with transportation
secretary pete butterjudge about the
urgency
of getting this done there's always been
a federal role and the federal role has
been underfunded and you can see it and
feel it
for months transportation secretary pete
butterjudge has been
increasing pressure on congress to act
on improving the nation's aging transit
network
last week swinging through oregon
arizona and illinois
touting regional benefits of federal
investment
not one of our airports is in the top 25
airports around the world
and all together it adds up to a country
that has fallen out of the top ten in
infrastructure
if we allow that to continue we cannot
be the world's leading economy for much
longer
the devil is going to be in the details
republican congressman rodney davis
represents central illinois and voted
against the 715 billion
house infrastructure bill which passed
earlier this month
was nothing but partisan and it would
unfairly punish
rural america that the expense of urban
america with some of the policies
that were listed in that bill davis says
the most
urgent need in his district is for road
and bridge repair
the republican chairman of chicago's
regional transit authority agrees
i ride into downtown chicago on a rail
car that was delivered when dwight
eisenhower
was the president many of those stations
were built
and designed when roosevelt was
president not franklin
but teddy there have been generations of
undefunding infrastructure
how likely is that to be fixed within a
single administration well one of the
things about
this moment is it represents a chance to
do something that will leave a mark not
just through the next
four or eight years but really through
the next 40 or 80.
now i also asked secretary but a judge
about the tax enforcement idea as a way
of funding some of the senate framework
which republicans now say is
off the table by the way the secretary
says that concept is about making rich
tax cheats pay their fair share he is
now of course open to other options
but he says gail with a midweek deadline
time is of the essence
all right errol you guys covered a lot
of ground a lot of ground in that
interview
i say you look good standing in front of
a building matching your suit
looks really nice appreciate it gail
thank you you're welcome station